Narrator:
These are the Sharks.
They have achieved
incredible success
as entrepreneurs and investors
in multiple sectors.
Laid Brand helps you get noticed
for all the right reasons.
You might get
a little bit tipsy.
Why are people buying this?
Because it's awesome.
We've done over $24 million
in gross revenue.
Narrator: This is the art
of doing business.
This is
the most ridiculous thing
I've heard
in a long time.
It's brilliant.
This is "Shark Tank."
People love it.
It's fun.
What, are you selling
to Martians?
That's why the universe
is broken.
I'm proof you can overcome
any obstacle.
Narrator: And tonight,
an unprecedented event
shocks the Sharks.
‐Aaah!
‐What?!
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a business
designed to make
get‐togethers with friends
more fun and interesting.
♪♪
‐Hey, I'm Harriet Mills.
‐And I'm Patrick Mills.
We're from Raleigh,
North Carolina,
and we're
the husband‐and‐wife duo
behind Wine & Design.
Today,
we're seeking $500,000
for 10% equity
in our company.
Wine & Design
are art studios
where the instructor teaches you
step‐by‐step painting tips
while you might get
a little bit tipsy.
Each session is
like a happy hour,
with music
and a party atmosphere.
There's nothing
more enjoyable
than a night of art class
with drinks, food, and friends.
Now, Sharks,
who's ready to get
their art buzz on
with us?
‐We are.
‐Yeah.
‐Yes, great.
‐Whoo‐hoo!
Bring on the wine.
Our lovely instructor,
Heather,
is gonna be teaching you
a portrait painting today.
‐Oh.
‐We have a little bit of help
with our figure model,
Richard.
Come on out, Richard!
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
Getting good now.
One of our most popular classes
is our bachelorette package.
[ Funky music plays ]
‐Oh, my God!
‐Aah!
What?!
[ Laughter ]
‐Just for you, Barbara.
And today ‐‐
tonight, we're actually
gonna be having
a bachelorette party
for Lori and Barbara!
‐Whoo!
‐Oh, my gosh!
I don't believe it.
It is time to get
this party started.
If y'all could get
y'all's apron on,
get ready
to start painting.
Seriously?
We're gonna get
the party started.
‐It's perfect, Mark.
‐All of us are painting?
‐All of us our painting.
‐Oh, my God.
Do you need help
with that?
I need help
with everything.
I'm shaking.
I know.
Okay.
I think everyone
might need to take a sip of wine
before we begin.
‐Oh, yeah.
Does Richard come with
every party?
Cheers, Kevin.
Heather: I'm gonna go ahead
and get y'all started.
Everyone has
their apron on.
We've got our boas on.
Barb, I've never
seen you speechless.
My name is Heather.
Ladies, thank you for having me.
We don't care
who you are, Heather.
To you, dear.
[ Laughter ]
So, you ready?
First thing you're gonna do
is you're gonna take
your large square brush.
We are putting water
all over our canvas,
just like I'm doing here.
And then you're gonna grab
your small brush.
And then I'm gonna dip it
in the yellow.
You'll just follow my lead,
okay?
Look at our beautiful Richard
for inspiration.
We're just gonna add yellow
in a few parts that we want to,
so just jump
right into the canvas.
Harriet: Are you ladies having
a good time
at your bachelorette night?
[ Laughs ] Uh, yeah.
We're in shock.
It's everything
I ever dreamed about ‐‐
I swear to God.
When you're done
with the yellow,
we're gonna wash off
our brush.
Can you believe this?
No.
So go ahead
and dip your paintbrush
in the pink.
If you are at that step,
you're gonna
follow my lead.
We're just gonna
add some beautiful pink
on these pecs.
The last step is the blue.
I want you to wash off
your brush, dab it a little bit.
We're going to go over
all the stencil marks,
so you're gonna kind of
draw a line here, here.
Pretty much all of these pecs,
these abs.
[ Laughing ] Are you doing
anything right over there?
It's a friggin'
masterpiece!
I'm telling you!
The last step is black,
and we are going to paint
the background of our canvas.
Once you are complete,
let me know,
and we will brag about
our final product.
I'm ready.
I'm done.
All right.
Ready?
Here it comes.
Wait, let's do it all
at the same time.
On the count of 3.
1, 2, 3...
[ Cheering ]
‐All right.
‐Look at Barb's!
You've done a great job.
You should be super‐proud
of yourselves.
So, I'm gonna
take my friend Richard.
‐Bye, Richard.
‐Bye.
Thank you. Thank you, ladies,
for your bachelorette party.
And thank you, guys,
for joining us.
Corcoran:
Oh, my God. [ Sighs ]
I hope y'all had a good time.
I know it's a lot.
Thank you, Richard.
This has been the best pitch
on "Shark Tank."
Oh, yes!
Bar none.
Very glad.
Yeah, can we find out
about the business,
how you guys
came up with it?
‐Yeah.
‐Give us the background.
Okay, so, six years ago,
me and a girlfriend went to
Charleston, South Carolina,
and went to
a similar concept,
with two bottles of wine,
and we had the best time.
I was like, "I can do this,
and I can do it better."
Within 60 days,
Wine & Design was born.
Patrick: So, this is a way
for people
to put down
their cellphones,
get away for two hours,
paint a painting for $35.
That's the cost?
$35?
$35.
Per person?
Yes.
So, we have 74 locations,
franchising.
‐74?
‐Nationwide?
74.
In how much time?
Um, well...
Five years.
Yeah, five years.
Five years. Wow.
So, six years ago,
I started this business.
Good for you.
Thank you.
That's amazing.
Good for her.
And so, how long
were you independent
before the first franchise?
About nine months.
And what were your sales
in that nine months?
Patrick: $250,000.
Wow!
How do you get your payment?
So, we take 6% royalties
off the gross revenue.
Like this year,
we will do around $10 million
in gross revenue...
Sharks: Wow.
...of all the locations,
so we'll bring in around
$600,000 cash in royalties.
Right now, our franchise fee
is at $25,000.
Oh!
So...
This is a dream business.
So we'll generate
around $200,000,
$250,000 off of that.
How many, um, territories
have you sold?
Or has it all been
one‐offs?
Right now,
we're in 14 states.
So far, I'm impressed,
okay?
Okay.
What is the 6% going to be
next year?
Next year,
we'll probably do anywhere
from $12 million
to $13 million in sales.
We will easily make,
I'd say,
right at $350,000
to $400,000 in profit.
We've done over $24 million
in gross revenue...
Wow.
... from all the stores.
What?!
We've never had
somebody on the show
that's franchised
a business
to the scale
that you have ‐‐
ever.
8 seasons.
Right.
Oh, and I will tell you
all of our franchisees
are women‐owned.
You know, 'cause this
is secondary income.
When I created
this business,
I really wanted
a flexible schedule with my son.
Guys, congratulations,
right?
What you've accomplished
is great.
Thank you.
But at the same time,
at 74 franchisees,
$300,000, $400,000 profits,
if you grow 10 times,
you're still not
up to making enough money
to return me my money.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Think about this problem
for a second.
Let's say I did your deal.
I give you
half a million dollars,
I get 10% of the company.
It takes me 16.6 years
to get my money back,
which is why
this is mis‐priced.
You know,
he's got a great point.
Yeah.
Like, the only way
this would make sense
for an investor
is if somebody bought
the whole company.
How much you willing to sell
the whole thing for,
just out of interest?
Eh, make us an offer.
Greiner: Why would you want to?
Oh, my God.
Why would you do that?
Everything's for sale.
Everything's for sale,
right?
Let's make an offer
and see.
You've got a pretty good
foothold in this.
Why would you want
to get out?
Well,
I personally think
that we're growing a little
too slow at this point
because, you know,
we do have competition,
and our competition
has a lot of studios.
We're the third‐largest
in the country right now.
Do you feel like
you're losing ground
or gaining ground on them?
I, per‐‐
I think we're ‐‐
I think we're kind of
staying at that third,
and we're not
getting higher.
I see. There's a lot
of competition out there.
Your valuation
is way off the charts.
I'm out.
Listen, very impressive.
I know people love this.
So, you have 74 franchises.
You have competition.
You're number 3.
And when something's
really crowded like that,
I get concerned
about how far it can grow.
I'm out.
Herjavec:
All right, where are we at?
Kevin, did you make
an offer?
O'Leary:
The only way this works is,
I give you $150,000
for the 10% equity.
That means I get
my money back
in between
three and four years,
which is about as long
as I want to wait.
And I'll loan you $350,000
as a line of credit at 12%.
It's 1% a month.
You draw it down as you need it.
That makes sense to me.
That's a decent return,
and I'm not stuck forever.
Hmm.
So back to loan shark.
Well, I think if you have
a better structure, Robert,
you should ‐‐
Well, I do have
a better structure, actually.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Harriet and Patrick have one
offer on the table, from Kevin,
for their art‐class company
Wine & Design.
But Robert
also seems interested.
Well, I think if you have
a better structure, Robert,
you should ‐‐
Well, I do have a better
structure, actually.
‐Well, let's hear it, then.
‐You do?
I'll make you an offer.
I'll give you
the $500,000,
But I get one‐third
of the business.
What a lot of people
don't realize is they think ‐‐
they start a business,
business takes off,
and they just get
to pull that money out.
Whenever you take a dollar
out of the business,
that's income paid
at a very high tax rate.
You've built
a successful business,
but you haven't been able
to pull that money out.
I'll buy one‐third of your stock
for $500,000.
Money's yours, but I own
one‐third of the business.
‐Do you understand it?
‐Yes, I do. I got that.
Greiner: It's shocking to me
that you bring a naked man
into the Tank
and you get two offers
from the two male Sharks.
I know!
Exactly.
I was thinking Barbara was gonna
be right there with us.
O'Leary: You know, they're two
very different offers.
What are you
going to do?
Well, let me ask you,
first of all, Kevin.
If we did partner up,
tell me the first thing
you would give
as a suggestion
on our company.
I would turn
my social media cannon on this
and push a tremendous amount
of data out
into the market
about our relationship.
I have
a $10 million wine business.
The first thing
I'm going to do
is figure out a cooperative deal
with you
to make sure the O'Leary Wines
are actually sold
at all these events
so we can co‐market.
I think the real goal
is to sign up 100 people.
It's a second income.
That's the story.
Get that out there,
you're gonna have people
signing up all the time.
That's the story,
and that's what my team
can build out there.
O'Leary: It's really about how
much equity you want to sell.
You got to make up your mind.
You're in the Shark Tank.
Now's your moment.
What are you gonna do?
♪♪
Kevin,
we'll take your deal.
Herjavec:
There you go, Mr. Wonderful.
‐I'm surprised.
‐Yeah.
Thank you very much.
Come here.
Oh, I'm excited.
Thank you.
Whoo! Nervous,
but we're excited.
Ohh!
You made a mistake!
I know. Well...
Thank you.
Thank you all so much.
‐Good luck, guys.
‐Ohh.
[ Squealing ]
Oh, my gosh!
We did it, we did it.
I can't believe
they took your offer.
Greiner: Wow.
I'm pretty happy
with that, actually.
I thought my offer
was really good.
Your offer was good.
They didn't want to give
up ‐‐ that's a good sign.
They didn't want to give up
that much.
Robert,
live and learn, grasshopper.
[ Laughs ]
Narrator:
This season, we were inspired
by the Sharks' stories.
Even with humble beginnings
and faced with challenges,
they were able to achieve
astounding success.
Herjavec: I think what makes me
different than the other Sharks
is I'm an actual immigrant.
That shapes a lot
of how I think and who I am.
Cuban: I grew up
in a working‐class family.
Nobody had high hopes for me,
but I was a hustler.
Corcoran: I had been dyslexic.
In those days,
you got labeled the dumb kid.
I've spent my entire life
trying to prove
that I am not stupid.
That's the truth.
That's what drives me.
John: I got left back in school
because I was kind of
hanging out in the streets.
But I had a really good mother.
She made me feel like
I was made for something bigger.
O'Leary:
If I could go back in time
and speak to my dad,
I'd say, "You taught me a lot
that's really helped me,
and just look
at our family today."
[ Voice breaking ]
It always cracks me up.
Narrator: And now the Sharks
are helping the entrepreneurs
achieve their dreams.
When do we get
to $10 million in revenue?
I think next year's
the year.
Doyle: Since partnering
with Mark and Chris,
we've done $5.46 million
in total rentals.
I love you guys.
[ Both laugh ]
Kannely: We got into
Bed Bath & Beyond nationwide.
It's only been
a few months,
and we're already
over $7 million in sales.
Weiss: We had never sold
an actual product.
Since "Shark Tank,"
we've sold $1 million.
Ali: We launched at retail
just three months ago,
and generated a half a million
dollars in sales.
Welcome to the family!
Nick: Before "Shark Tank,"
we did $200,000 in sales.
Two years later, we've done
$13 million in sales.
Sales are now $16 million,
and I can't believe it.
Quackenbush: Seven years ago,
we started out in a tent.
Today,
$47 million in sales.
We've created
over 500 jobs.
We never thought
we'd grow this big,
and it's thanks to you guys.
This has been awesome.
Narrator: And showing
that entrepreneurship
can change the world
for the better.
Thinking
about our journey...
[ Voice breaking ]
I get emotional every time.
I mean, I was
a struggling mom to them,
and overnight,
my whole life changed.
Rick: We've been able to open
seven orphanages in India,
and we have plans to
open schools in India and Nepal
to give these kids
a very bright future.
Patel: My parents came
to this country with nothing.
When my dad looks at me now,
I can tell I'm
his American Dream come true.
Cruse:
As military spouses, we are
doing everything that we can
to support our service member
so they can do the things
that they need to do
to protect our country.
Lee: This entrepreneur's journey
is a long road.
But once you get there,
it is amazing.
Cuban:
The key is finding something
you really like to do
and then being great at it.
My goal is go out there
and help as many kids as I can
to accomplish their dreams.
That's what "Shark Tank"
is all about.
That's what the American Dream
Welcome to
the United States of America.
[ Applause ]
John: I had no idea about
the power of "Shark Tank"
all around the globe.
People from all around the world
have been coming up to me
and telling me how "Shark Tank"
has helped change their lives.
And I'm so proud
to be part of it.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a futuristic version
of a common product.
♪♪
I'm Joe.
And I'm Jake.
Our company is Rocketbook,
and we're seeking
$400,000 for 10%.
And we make...
Both:
Notebooks from the future.
[ Laughter ]
It doesn't matter whether
you're a student or a Shark.
We just can't let go
of pen and paper.
It's our most natural
form of expression.
But meanwhile, the rest
of our lives are digital
and accessible
across any device.
That's why
we created Rocketbook.
It's really just
a pen‐and‐paper notebook,
but take notes
in your Rocketbook
and scan them
with the Rocketbook app
to instantly blast those notes
to popular cloud services
instantly organized
for you.
At the bottom
of each Rocketbook page
are seven symbols.
And you decide
what they do.
So, Mark, maybe use
that diamond symbol
so that those notes
go to your startup pitch folder
inside of Google Docs.
Maybe, Lori, how about
you use the star symbol
so when you mark that,
those notes go ‐‐ Zhoo! ‐‐
right to
your assistant's e‐mail.
Now that your notes
are safe
in all your favorite
cloud services,
you really don't need
this hard copy anymore,
which is why we designed
our first notebook,
the Rocketbook Wave,
to be reusable.
That's right.
You can make your entire
notebook contents disappear.
For this,
I'm gonna need an assistant.
Uh, Robert, if you will?
Oh.
Please don't
make me disappear.
[ Laughs ]
Your pen.
Thank you.
And if you will,
just choose any random page
in your Rocketbook.
Draw some doodle,
maybe your signature ‐‐
whatever you'd like.
Fantastic.
O'Leary:
Beautiful work, Robert.
Okay, Robert,
check this out.
I'm just gonna use the
Rocketbook app to scan this in
so that later,
we can make these notes
reappear.
Oh, that's cool.
Oh, cool.
Mm‐hmm.
Okay, for this part,
Sharks,
this does require
a fairly bulky piece of hardware
that we had to bring along
with us ‐‐
The Rocket Reset Chamber.
[ Laughter ]
Greiner: A microwave?
It's from the future.
And, Robert, you're gonna
microwave your notebook here.
And Commander Epstein
is gonna give you
a little mug of water
to place right on the circles
on the cover.
Okay.
Let's close it up.
What, you really have
to put a mug of water on there?
You really do ‐‐
That's an important part
of controlling
the heating process
so it works
in every microwave.
All right, Robert, it's time
to nuke your notebook.
Don't do it, Robert.
No!
Aaah!
Why don't we have a seat?
I'll hand out samples,
and I'll explain
to you the process.
Thank you. Thank you.
The only reason
I'm microwaving this book
is to erase it so I don't
have to buy a new one.
What's the matter
with you guys?
Don't you want to sell
a second book to everybody?
[ Laughter ]
Why would I want
to erase it?
Why wouldn't I want to
make them throw it out
or burn it
and buy another one?
Well ‐‐
Thank goodness
you've met me.
[ Laughter ]
You just solved
your whole problem.
Thank you.
Well, we're doing
pretty well.
We've sold about 75,000
of these so far.
Have you really?!
We have.
What, are you selling
to Martians?
People love it.
It's fun.
Herjavec:
How much do they cost?
They cost $27 retail.
So, your total sales
are what?
Damn! Good for you!
Epstein:
$2.2 million.
How much? How much?
Herjavec: $2.2 million?!
What?!
How much do they sell for?
$2.2 million.
Herjavec: We are taking you
way more seriously now.
Hey, hang on a second.
Yeah.
Did you actually prove
it erased my page?
Let's do it.
Hmm?
‐Oh!
‐[ Gasps ]
‐That's amazing!
‐Amazing, Robert!
It's the Rocketbook!
And I just lost a sale...
Cuban: Okay, wait, wait,
wait a second.
...'cause the guy
doesn't have to buy it again.
Um, we're not losing
too many sales.
Why are people buying this?
Because it's awesome.
And, actually ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
No, no!
People come
for the microwaveabilty.
They're attracted to that,
but they stick around
for the Rocket system.
O'Leary: Okay, guys,
any iPad now with a pen
can do this
right to the cloud.
That's true,
but it's another gadget to lose.
It's another battery
to charge.
I get it.
I just ‐‐ I'm just trying
to wrap my head around
nuking the book.
I just ‐‐
Herjavec: I love the gimmick.
It works.
‐But ‐‐
‐Well, wait.
What makes it work?
Greiner: I have two questions.
Let me ask ‐‐ what's
the science that makes it work?
There's a lot
of engineering
that has gone
into the construction
of a microwave‐safe
notebook.
And we have
patents pending.
What does the water
do to it?
The water absorbs a lot
of the microwave energy,
and it slows down
the heating process.
This is the funniest,
wackiest, most ridiculous thing
I've heard in a long time.
It's brilliant.
Thank you.
My fear is,
it's a great gimmick.
And two to three years
from now,
I think people
will get tired of it.
So I'm out.
Guys, I don't get
the schtick.
I mean, I applaud
the sales you've had,
but I'm amazed that you've sold
as much as you have.
And I think you've got other
Sharks that are interested.
I don't see it.
I'm out.
Thank you for that.
Guys, I don't ‐‐
This is so crazy ‐‐
so crazy that you can get
millions in sales
by nuking a notebook
in a microwave.
I'm not even sure I'm
on the planet Earth right now.
There's nobody in the world
that would take paper
and erase it
when I could sell
another one.
In my universe,
that's a dark force,
an evil force
I can't understand.
I'm out.
I have to say ‐‐
I never, ever would dream
that anybody could reinvent
a binder, a paper binder.
I mean, like, you just ‐‐
A notebook is a notebook.
That, by the way, you can buy
in any Staples for a buck‐20.
A $1.20 book is now $27
'cause you can stick it
in a frickin' microwave!
That's why
I'm so disturbed.
I don't think the price
is bad for what it is.
You've proven the concept,
but I don't like all the steps.
I don't like
that I actually have to
take a picture
of each page,
and then, you know,
when I'm done,
I have to microwave it,
put the water on it,
and all of that.
[ Laughs ]
I get how people
might like it,
you know, one time,
tell their friends,
this or that,
but then after a while,
I think it fizzles.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Well, Mark's still in.
Guys [Laughs]
just the microwave ‐‐
isn't that what sells it ‐‐
period, end of story?
Lemay:
No, absolutely not.
That is a differentiator,
but people are buying these
and repurchasing them
because of
the Rocket System.
Where do you see yourselves
in five years?
Well, I think we're gonna
build this into a major brand,
just like people thought,
"What could a Post‐it note be?"
Well, now it takes up
all of Staples.
We're gonna be like
the operating system for paper.
Greiner: But a Post‐it note ‐‐
all you have to do is
you write
and you stick it on something.
Operating system
for paper.
We're gonna have
digitally enabled paper
and office products.
[ Laughs ]
Guys, I mean...
I'm out.
I'm sorry.
Thank you.
‐Congrats.
‐Unbelievable.
‐Thank you.
‐Bye, guys.
Oh, my God.
Lemay: Of course we would've
loved to work with the Sharks
and secured a deal
with them,
but it's not always a fit,
and that's quite all right.
We're having
a great time,
and, you know,
it's onward and upward for us.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a business
hoping to capitalize
on our desire to be attractive.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Adam Rauch.
I'm Derek Shaw, and we are
the founders of Laid Brand.
Today, we are respectfully
and humbly
offering 30% of our business
for $30,000.
Laid Brand helps you get noticed
for all the right reasons ‐‐
with pheromones.
Whether you're trying
to attract a mate
or get that extra boost
of confidence,
pheromones can help you
achieve those desires.
We are the first
and only line
of professional
hair‐care products
with a proprietary blend
of intoxicating pheromones
specifically designed to make
you feel confident, beautiful,
and create
positive social reactions
from those around you.
When a Laid Brand girl
walks into the room,
she instantly gets noticed.
A Laid Brand girl
gets the attention
of the cute guy in line
for coffee
because she exudes beauty
on the outside.
A Laid Brand girl
nails her job interview
because she believes
in herself.
But Laid Brand
doesn't just smell good.
It leaves your hair
looking absolutely stunning.
That's right. So we have all
these pheromones flying around,
and all of our confidence
will compel you guys
to join us to bring Laid Brand
to the world.
And with that,
Jacqueline here
is gonna hand out
some samples for you
to get some
of that phero‐fabulous fragrance
and see what you like.
Okay.
[ Chuckles ]
So, what Jacqueline's
handing out
are three
of our women's products.
Across the line,
all of the products
will protect
and enhance color.
They will also protect, hydrate,
and repair the hair.
And they're also paraben‐,
sulfate‐, and cruelty‐free.
What is a pheromone?
So, yeah,
they're chemical messengers
that are excreted
throughout sweat
and, you know,
other bodily fluids.
Each person's are unique.
Exactly. However ‐‐
Truth is,
in the letters from Napoleon
discovered
decades after his death...
[ Laughing ]
Oh, my gosh.
...there were
many, many, many letters
to his lover, Josephine.
And when he was
on a campaign
and he'd known
he'd won the battle
and was gonna return home,
he would send a runner
all the way back to her
to tell her
not to bathe for a week...
That's so gross.
... because he wanted
the full essence of her
when he finally arrived home.
And that was
the very first use
of the human pheromone
in documented letters.
That's disgusting
and...
Not at all.
I don't even believe it.
This is why Kevin
doesn't shower or bathe.
[ Laughs ]
Adam, do you see
any challenge
with the name Laid Brand?
Would a woman want to be
a Laid Brand kind of girl?
Absolutely.
You would be shocked
at the provocative nature
of the naming
for all cosmetics now.
I don't get it,
but when I walk into Sephora
and I see
all these millennial girls
hovered around
the Urban Decay and the NARS,
not the old‐school stuff
that's boring,
I say, "Wow,
we have something here."
But why not a guy's brand?
I thought it was
for men, too.
Herjavec: I thought
it was a guy product,
especially
with the name.
Yeah.
This brand had a genesis
from starting with one product
that was for men.
Oh.
So, to give you
the full timeline,
he started a product
in 2010, all right?
He got to a certain point,
and he said, "I need some help."
And so he found me.
I had worked
for big companies
in beauty care
for 13 years,
mostly on the female side.
And I said,
"You know what ‐‐
you have more than
just a single product.
You have
a potential brand here.
More than just a brand,
you have a potential lifestyle."
So we launched
a couple different pilots ‐‐
male and female products
with different types
of pheromones ‐‐
and we launched it
into the market,
and we sold $27,000
in the first six months
at one salon
and e‐commerce.
So, over the last three months,
what are your sales?
Zero ‐‐
and here's why.
We stopped.
You stopped?
Because it wasn't working?
So ‐‐ So, no.
You know, we had to formulate
the products and test them
in market for a while before
we even went to another salon.
I was ‐‐ I was dying
because all I wanted to do
was go and sell it,
but I couldn't.
I had to wait
because the products
needed to be good, right?
[ Laughter ]
I'm so worried this guy's gonna
spontaneously combust.
Me too. Me too.
[ Laughs ]
We balance
each other out.
So, you did a test pilot.
That's fine.
What we're doing ‐‐
it's so unique.
Nobody else is doing it.
‐It's not so unique, though.
It's not so unique.
Your name is unique.
Using pheromones
is not unique.
And it's not
like those shelves ‐‐
In hair care, it is.
Put that aside.
Have you talked to women?
Greiner:
Yeah, yeah. What did you do
as market research
to find out
that women like this
and respond to this
in a positive way?
From surveys through our salon
to our online sales.
And we did sell
internationally.
And you'd be amazed
at the pheromone community.
I mean, we were shocked.
‐There's a pheromone ‐‐
‐There are pheromone followers?
The pheromone community
is out there.
‐They meet on Friday nights.
‐They are enthusiasts.
I mean, pheromones in products
are huge in Europe.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Derek, to ‐‐ to ‐‐
All right, let me ‐‐
let me tell you
where I'm at.
Um, you just made
the point ‐‐
Adding pheromones to a product
is not unique.
It's not difficult,
and it's not proprietary.
And, you know,
most importantly,
I like to invest in people
who have a lot of energy.
Uh‐huh.
You were very flat today.
You were ‐‐
you had no energy.
[ Laughter ]
I was gonna say,
"Oh, no."
Uh, it's gonna be
a challenge.
I'm out.
Thank you
for your consideration.
Thank you for you time.
We appreciate it.
Greiner: You know,
no one even asked you ‐‐
what does a bottle cost?
Yeah, it's blended,
$2.50.
No, if I'm a customer
and I go online?
Yes, online ‐‐ $24.99,
and we intentionally ‐‐
Those margins
are fantastic,
which is why you have
so much competition.
You said earlier
in your presentation,
you've walked into Sephora,
obviously been
in the ground floor
of large department stores.
That real estate
is the most valuable on Earth.
They don't
let small guys in.
You can bounce off the walls
all day long.
They're not gonna
give you shelf space.
I'm out.
There's so many things I see
as a problem with this.
First off,
there's huge competition ‐‐
enormous
in the hair‐care industry.
Secondly, I sprayed it.
I didn't smell anything.
I sprayed it on Kevin ‐‐
didn't do anything.
[ Laughter ]
There's so much here
that you're up against.
I'm out.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
I disagree with Kevin.
I think you guys
can grind out a living.
Is it gonna be huge?
Who knows? Right?
But $30,000 doesn't get you
in the door for 10 salons.
And so, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Mark, I take objection
to you
giving them encouragement.
So...
Grind out a living
as long as they don't
have to eat or pay rent.
Cuban:
Kevin's never seen hard work,
so he doesn't
quite understand it.
I don't doubt for a moment
your sincerity.
You're just so genuine.
Thank you.
Uh, here's the problem.
I feel like I am
a walking sex goddess out there.
[ Laughs ]
We do not disagree.
Women are attracted to me.
Men are attracted to me.
All these people
are attracted to me.
‐It's true!
‐Dogs are attracted to me.
I can't even imagine
what would happen
if I put this stuff
on myself.
[ Laughs ]
But I'm afraid of your
pheromones, honest to God,
put on a person like me,
so I'm out.
Thank you very much.
Good luck, guys.
Thank you.
All right, thank you all
so much.
Thank you so much.
We appreciate it.
Bye.
All right.
Rauch: Oh, man.
Oh, that was awesome.
[ Sighs ]
We tried.
It's all right.
You know, we did
everything we could.
And we know it's unique,
so it's all good.
Yeah.
They had good advice
for us,
and we'll take that
to heart.
But you know what?
At the end of the day,
we put all of our heart
and soul into this,
and we know we're still gonna
make it huge.
♪♪
My name is Heather, and I live
in the Poconos, Pennsylvania,
with my two daughters,
Casey and Sarah.
Ooh!
Oh, that's beautiful.
I've been working
in the bridal industry
for 11 years.
I love working with brides
because it's a happy day
in their lives.
They're glowing.
They're excited.
And I'm excited
to work with them.
I came up with my product
after watching brides
try on their gowns
and realizing
there was a problem
that needed to be solved.
So, what are you guys
gonna paint?
I had to put the product idea
on the side for about a decade
because I wanted
to start a family.
And nobody believed in the idea
as much as I did.
I'm divorced now,
but I never stopped thinking
about my product idea.
And although I didn't have
as much encouragement
as I would have liked back then,
I have a lot of it now.
All we need is
those little strings on the top,
and it would be perfect.
I put in $40,000
of my retirement money
in this product.
That wasn't easy,
but I'm glad that I did it.
I found the confidence in myself
to help my business
go all the way.
With a Shark behind me,
we will be unstoppable.
♪♪
Hi.
My name is Heather.
I'm from the Poconos,
Pennsylvania,
and I'm the inventor
of the Bridal Buddy.
I'm seeking $75,000
for 10% equity in my company.
[ Wedding march plays ]
Weddings are a magical time
for brides,
a day every girl dreams about.
But there's
a not‐so‐glamorous side.
Imagine ‐‐
you said your vows.
You're at your reception.
You're eating, drinking,
dancing,
having a great time
in your gorgeous gown.
And all of a sudden,
it hits you.
I have to pee!
What do you do?
[ Laughter ]
You could recruit
the help of your bridesmaids,
who are off at the bar
two sangrias deep
with the groomsmen,
to help fluff your gown.
But I have to pee now!
What do you do?
Sharks,
in comes my invention ‐‐
the Bridal Buddy.
It's a sheer, lightweight slip
worn under the gown
that helps you bag up
your dress...
Oh, my...
...so that you can use
the bathroom on your own.
[ Laughs ]
You simply bag up
your gown.
[ Laughter ]
Wow!
Arms through the holes.
you'll notice them
as your "something blue."
‐Come on!
‐Wow!
That is crazy.
[ Laughs ]
Then you simply adjust
your drawstring.
And voilà.
Oh, my...
And go.
[ Laughter ]
And as you can see ‐‐
Well, we need the sigh.
We need the sigh of relief.
[ Sighs ]
Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
And as you can see,
it bags up her gown,
and so she can use
the bathroom on her own,
and it protects the gown
in the bathroom stall.
Wow.
And when
you're finished...
You just walk out
like that.
...simply undo your gown,
unfurl it,
and you're ready
to party.
Stenlake: Use the bathroom
on their own with dignity,
one Bridal Buddy at a time.
Thank you.
Marissa, would you mind
handing out samples for them?
We have samples?
I was thinking maybe
you could try it on.
Thank you.
Here you go, Lori.
Corcoran: Pretty packaging.
O'Leary:
Normally, you would take
one of your bridesmaids
into the washroom with you,
where she would assist you,
which is the long‐term tradition
of the bridesmaid ‐‐
to be the maid of the bride,
to assist her
in her toilet duties.
[ Laughter ]
You can't listen to him.
Is that why bridesmaids
were first invented?
‐Exactly. It is.
‐That's exactly ‐‐
I am Mr. Wonderful.
I'm the king
of love and weddings,
so I know this.
Heather, how did you come up
with this great idea?
Well, I started working
in the bridal industry
in 1998.
I did all sorts of jobs
in the bridal industry.
But the one question
they would always ask is,
"How do I go to the bathroom
in this thing?"
Wow.
And they say,
"Oh, you can take your girls
in with you.
You can wear
a garbage bag."
That was another thing.
I'm like, "No, no, no, no, no."
A garbage bag?
Garbage bag?
Yes, a garbage bag.
That would be
disgustingly hot and sticky.
Who wants to wear that
under your beautiful gown?
I don't.
So what I did was,
in around 2002,
I came up
with a prototype.
And I was expecting
my children,
and I had to put it aside.
So I was a stay‐at‐home mom
for a few years.
And then I went, finally, to
live on my own with my children.
And in the house,
I found the bag that I had kept
of all my notes
and all my materials,
and it just hit me ‐‐
I'm like, "It's time."
It is time.
So I came up with a
better version of the original.
What year did you
start it again?
Um, it was...2015.
You created it
in 2002,
but you only launched
in 2015.
Yeah.
What happened
in that 13 years
that you didn't move forward
with it?
Um...you know,
life happens.
Without going into
too much detail,
all I'll say is this.
[ Sighs ]
You know,
surround yourself
with positive,
encouraging people
because that is the way
you get ahead.
And I have found that out
the hard way.
Unfortunately, it took me
many years to figure that out.
What made the change?
Because
I believed in myself.
And I kept working on it
and working on it
and trying to get
the best possible version of it.
And here I am,
and I'm proof
that you can overcome
any obstacle
and get
where you want to be.
Focus on the future.
I am done with the past,
but it is
a learning experience for me.
They always say
look back to learn,
look forward to succeed.
You're exactly right.
Do you have any sales,
or are you
still in development?
We are up to $195,000
in sales.
Wow.
And what does one cost?
One costs $29.95.
What does it cost you
to make it?
$14 apiece.
Even at low volumes
at a $14 cost,
this product could easily
support a $39.95 price point.
I started at $59.95.
Yes!
Now you're talking.
What happened, though?
Then what happened?
And that was great.
And I've had brides tell me
it's way too expensive.
No!
It's too much.
It's like, no,
why would you ‐‐
Did your sales
start flatlining?
It did. After a little while,
it started to go down.
Heather, who's the biggest
retailer for wedding?
I forget their name
right now.
David's Bridal?
Yeah. Have you
ever approached them?
I have.
And what did they say?
Their response was,
is it doesn't
go with their merchandise.
But it's a very needed thing.
They don't like
the potty association?
Exactly.
Cuban: Heather, let me kind of
clear things up a little bit.
Congratulations to you
for overcoming your obstacles
and chasing your dreams.
I think you're gonna be
very successful.
But the wedding industry is
not something I want to pursue,
so I'm out.
Thank you, Mark.
You're welcome.
$195,000 for a $29 item ‐‐
that's great.
I mean, you're ‐‐ you're ‐‐
you're going somewhere.
I think the price point
is too low.
I think that...
I would agree.
...it's gonna be
very difficult to sell it
one at a time online,
unless you can make
that retail association,
'cause most brides would buy it
at the point of purchase.
For that reason, I'm out.
Okay.
I would like to say something
on Heather's behalf.
Heather is
an incredible human being.
When she approached me
about this,
I was already working
two jobs.
And the idea
of tronking around on Sundays
at bridal shows
for eight hours
in a cold auditorium
was not all that appealing.
But you know what?
I got up here,
and I showed my underpants
to the international community
because I believe
in Heather.
And sometimes
when you love somebody,
it means you show everybody
your underpants.
She is brilliant.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm telling you
right now ‐‐
the way that brides
respond to this product,
I think some of y'all
are making a mistake.
They freak out.
I had one lady tell me
she had to army‐crawl
under her friend's wedding dress
and tear her Spanx apart
with her bare hands.
This is a product
that almost every single bride
is going to want.
Marissa,
you're a great salesperson.
Do you have a piece
of the company?
I'm the saleslady.
She's the inventor,
I'm the flasher.
Herjavec:
Marissa, first of all,
that is the best speech
we've ever had on here.
Heather is
an inspiration.
She clawed her way here.
That's a very ‐‐
Hang on, hang on.
You are extremely loyal
and very good friend.
After having heard that ‐‐
And when I first started,
there were several people
that were people
that I knew
that just weren't
believers.
And, you know,
what that did for me
is it made a fire inside of me
to prove them wrong.
And that's
what I see from you.
They actually did you
a favor
because they made you
stronger.
So, what are you missing,
do you feel?
I need connections.
I need help to get
into those ‐‐
for the companies
to listen to me.
I have an offer for you.
I think I can help you
with the manufacturing of it.
I think I could get
your costs way down
so that you get it into retail
at a reasonable price.
Mr. Wonderful
has a platform ‐‐
Honeyfund
and all the other things.
So we have discussed
going in together
to give you an offer.
We are thinking,
what if you bring her in?
So ‐‐
I have to see her
in the deal.
as part of the deal.
He wants to see her in
because you're by yourself.
Right.
So you handle
whatever parts of the business
that we're not
talking about here
that you know
are important.
Still got to hit the shows
with Marissa.
You still got to go ‐‐
And you handle
the rest of the sales,
and you help her.
And we'd all be equal
partners ‐‐ 25, 25, 25, 25.
If we get
all the great purchase orders,
we'll help you fund
those purchase orders,
specifically
for purchase orders.
So you're taking
50% of her business.
Yes.
Yes, it's gonna need that.
Herjavec: Well, hang on.
But I'm gonna take over
manufacturing.
You're taking
75% of the business,
because your condition
is she has to give up ‐‐
Marissa has to be
part of it.
Well, how nice.
They're giving you a tip.
If you want her ‐‐
I forbid you!
♪♪
Narrator: Two Sharks are out,
but Lori and Kevin
have presented a unique offer
to Heather
for her bridal‐accessory
company, Bridal Buddy.
You're taking
75% of the business,
because your condition
is that she has to give ‐‐
Marissa has to be part of it.
She has to be.
Well, how nice.
They're giving you a tip,
If you want her ‐‐
I forbid you!
If you want her
to be part of it.
Well, hang on. Your offer
is $75,000 for 75%.
50%.
Well, no.
Let's be real.
No.
Because
she has to give up ‐‐
He wants her to have that.
Let's do it
a different way, Heather.
Heather goes from owning
100% to 25%.
Period, end of story.
Erase that.
She's working
for you, then.
I have an offer.
We can't bring her in
like that.
Let them figure this out.
Excuse me.
You guys ‐‐
You guys discuss
that very complicated thing.
We're starting over.
I have
a very simple offer.
When you told me
that it took 10‐plus years
to get going,
I'm telling in my head,
I was out right away.
I'm thinking,
"How does it take 10 years?"
But you know
what I've learned?
I've learned as long
as you get back up there,
who the heck cares
when it is?
But you stand and you get
counted for yourself.
And I'm proud of that.
And I was also reflecting
back on my boyfriend,
who ran off
and married my secretary,
who gave me
the gift of my life,
when he said, "You'll never
succeed without me."
All right?
So I get you.
You're never going down
again.
All right,
now here's my offer.
I think the only
missing ingredient you have
is salesmanship.
And Marissa is
phenomenal at it.
So here's the offer.
It's $75,000
for 33% of your business.
I'm gonna go back
because I didn't like the offer
that we gave before.
Then why did you offer it?
I want to erase it.
No, don't look back.
Look forward.
Okay,
I'm looking forward.
So, I don't want it
to have to be
that you have to be
a partner.
So if you want to have anything
to do with me with this,
we have to
get rid of that.
That was a good offer.
Here's the deal.
You get two Sharks.
We'll drop down to 40%,
so we have 20% each.
You decide
what to do with Marissa,
but you still have
60% of the company.
You decide what you want.
There's no contingency
that she ha‐‐
You work if you want,
you work if you don't want.
Heather, you have two offers.
Sometimes offers go away.
Stenlake: Absolutely.
Lori, would you be willing
to come down a little bit
in your percentage?
To what?
30%.
Kevin?
Wow. Tough decision,
Heather.
What about Barb's offer?
I like Barbara ‐‐
What about 33 1/3%?
Corcoran:
You know what?
I'll do that deal.
Kevin?
$75,000 for 30%.
I would do the deal
if Kevin will do the deal.
Let me understand this ‐‐
You'll do the deal,
$75,000 for 30%.
We get 15% each.
Okay, done.
♪♪
You doing it?
It's a deal.
I don't believe it!
Thank you, Barbara.
Why didn't you talk
with your partner?
Congratulations.
Mwah!
You're a genius.
You are a freaking genius.
Marissa.
You go, girl.
I'm so proud of you!
[ Laughs ]
I'm so proud.
Oh, you did so good!
Thank you
for bringing me here.
Thanks for standing up
for me.
Oh, my gosh,
of course.
I'm not gonna let them
push you around.
I don't care who they are.
Come here.
Thanks for being my voice.